Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
So a UFC two oh seven
that was one of the crick.
One of the craziest events of all
time and watching that main event was,
it was like there was,
it was surreal.
First of all,
it's surreal because I was,
my body was all weirded out because I was,
it was a little out of it,
about the past,
about the shit all over my chair.
But it was also,
it was just like that was the least
competitive like main event other than
although in Mcgregor,
but that was one dynamic shot
to the Chin and knocked him out.
Like everything about that was off kick.
Can you knit,
can you think about another main event,
championship level where it was
that kind of big of a discrepancy?
You know what I'm saying?
Like it was even a fight and I,
and I think leading up to it,
there was some kind of red flags
that you saw leading up to it.
If you think back now that we can shape
though everybody said right physically,
physically,
physically.
She looked great but like what's,
what kind of sparring was she doing?
You know,
one of the things I was thinking
when she was hitting pads,
she's standing there
hitting pads with Edmond.
I was like,
they're standing right
in front of each other.
Like she's not moving like
she's just hitting pads,
pop,
pop up.
Ads are tough to tell though,
right?
Because sometimes the
do it for the camera.
If the countdown cruiser and you
don't want to show your new shit,
but also what did people
think was going to happen?
Like did you think this whole time
when she's shooting these movies,
doing Suzie admin her come up with a
plan for her to stick on the outside jab
and move.
That's not,
that's not in her DNA.
That's person.
Anyway.
She had to close the distance and clinch,
you know,
I should have been the only plant.
The idea of standing with
Amanda Nunez is just ridiculous.
The difference in punching
power is like literally double,
but we've seen her fight they punches
before who batch could hit pretty hard.
I'm not saying similar but no,
I'm saying what batch did she,
she was a,
has decent to power and
she's a very aggressive,
she throws volume strikes
but she throws her arms.
She doesn't hit nearly as hard as Amanda,
Amanda torques or whole body in the shit.
I agree Jo.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's an batches arms for this long is
fine and Dan got damn telephone poles and
that's all fine.
But don't you think the game plan should
have been get her to the ground and she
tried that a little bit.
She didn't,
she was already lit up.
She wasn't there though.
Mentally.
That's what I'm saying.
There's,
there's things leading up to it and I
think the biggest red red flag for me,
and you know Dana better than anyone,
he's a promoter through
and through one of the,
if not the best of all time.
I can't think of another one.
Don King I guess,
but still for him to say,
yeah,
you can skip all the media shit
and just focus on the fight.
I was like,
God,
that just doesn't seem right.
You know why she's managed by,
or she's handled by William
Morris Endeavor WME cause
WME owns UFC now I'm aware
of.
I'm sure that's what,
that's the only way I was his decision.
It was his decision.
He was,
I'm the one who led,
we agreed to this.
It was in her contract.
It's a one time thing
I'm never doing again.
I thought,
God damn,
that is so she put it in the contract.
She must have said,
this is what I want to do.
I don't want to talk to any media.
I just want to go out and
try the red flag to you.
Not Have Connor did it.
I mean,
Connor doesn't have the choice coming.
Connor did it,
but if Connor did it,
if Connor said,
fuck all this fucking media,
I'm going to Dublin,
I'm going to train.
He would never do that.
If he did,
I'd have Z.
It's a proper red flagged out
to anyone involved at all.
Dana,
this say it's all good.
[inaudible] here's the thing,
she goes out,
grabs hold of men,
Nunez,
flips her on her head,
semi unconscious catches
her in the arm bar.
She's the new champion.
35 seconds.
You're not saying this.
I disagree.
No,
you wouldn't say there's a red flag.
If she went out and dominated and he'd
got an arm bar in the first round,
you would definitely not say skip
skipping the media as a red flag.
So then she only saying it because
this is like armchair quarterbacking.
It's not though,
because I said it's a red flag
before this because if she,
so if she did interviews afterwards,
let's say she went out
there dominator in a minute,
submitter and then shoot
interviews afterwards,
that's a little different.
You know what I'm saying?
Cause she just saying I'm
not doing any meat at all.
Even posts posts.
Yeah.
Well she doesn't want to talk after that.
I mean why would you want
to tell him the other thing,
the whole cell on this,
was she serious?
Now she's saying,
oh my God,
she's focused knowing her as you
serious now with the whole thing,
the whole thing was like this big
obvious marketing perspective.
Like a promotional Hollywood perspective.
Like they had the movie which is a really
good like got you pumped up like that
whole thing about her coming back and
they lift up the garage door [inaudible]
working out really hard and it's they,
what they did is they
created a great hype piece.
You know if you're in the
Ronda Rousey business.
Exactly.
Amanda Nunez going exactly
the best was the best.
Was there a picture promoting this UFC
and there's a picture of Ronda and her
fight care and Rhonda in the street
clothes cause she's back two oh seven it's
like fuck man.
What about Amanda and
when I say this crazy,
make sure who did that picture that he
was at an official UFC picture official
UFC kind of a social media post.
Wow.
It's crazy man.
Cause now what do you do?
It's also crazy because it's
crazy for a marketing perspective.
I mean,
a lot of people thought that Rhonda
was going to win a lot of people.
I was 100% who the fuck knows me too.
That's exactly how I felt when I
was watching that fight play out.
I was like,
who the fuck knows?
I mean you could see,
look,
Rhonda looked like she
was in amazing shape.
You think about the things that Ron
has been able to do in the past to like
Sarah McMahon.
You would think,
well maybe she ties her up in a clinch
blasts or with a knee to the body,
flips her on her back and arm bars are,
who the fuck knows if she
gets you on the ground?
Her arm bar technique is outstanding.
It's just what some of the best,
if not the best I've ever
scene that could have happened,
but it was so who the fuck knows?
But the moment she got hit,
she's not moving her head at all.
She's standing straight up in the air and
then I see her legs get close together
and that's when you know someone's really
hurt when someone gets lit up and then
they start moving,
but their legs are too close together.
She's not working right.
It's not like they,
they kind of know what to do,
but it's just not,
they're not their balances and good.
There was no head movement.
She was probably hurt with like the
second or third punch that Amanda hit her
with.
She was probably on Queer Street.
That's a woke her up.
She didn't know where
she was until she got it.
Joe,
look at that when she got hit.
When you go,
Ooh,
she's hurt.
She's hurt.
Look at her face and you
even said it yourself.
She drew up a kick.
She threw some kicks to
try to keep Amanda off.
I think she didn't realize.
I think when Amanda Hits Girls,
they just go,
Holy Shit.
Yup,
but what else would you,
what else would you expect in that?
You know what I'm saying?
Like you,
you don't realize till you get hit,
but you,
you hear all the criticism now of,
uh,
Edmond who's obviously a terrible coach,
but take that out of it.
If,
if,
if you bring a horse to
water and they can't drink,
there's nothing else you can do.
So if mentally she doesn't
want to be in there,
do you think weight didn't
want to be in there?
Uh,
did they say that it didn't look like the
same tenacity that were used to seeing
chill?
It's super tenacious
until she got cracked.
Joe Is 44 seconds.
Snapchat,
that First Jab,
she got hurt with a right hand.
May Be 10 50.
We didn't watch the whole fight fight.
It's 40 seconds.
Go fight.
You could,
uh,
it's on youtube.
It's everywhere.
As a matter.
I mean,
you know what I mean?
Tough fighters before.
Like what do you think it is?
I don't understand why.
Why are you even saying this?
You see that she got hit and you,
she,
she got hurt and you've
been hitting hurt before.
Who Know what happens?
You just don't know what
the fuck's going on.
Correct.
However,
I don't think that jab put her lights out.
It wasn't just a jab dude.
She hit her with a refresh jab that
landed the first time she went into Cape
close desk.
First Jab landed,
but then she got hit with many punches.
I don't understand why you're
confused as to the result.
I mean she got hit by the biggest
power punch her in the hundred 35 pound
division by far.
There's not a single girl in that
division that punches like Amanda does.
I agree with that,
but not right.
It wasn't a right hand right away.
Yes it was.
It was a jab right away.
Right hand right after that.
Once,
once run to try to close distance was
40 seconds of Amanda Punching Rhonda in
the face until Rhonda would
out like the idea that some,
something's confusing that she didn't
look like she wanted to be there.
She was hurt multiple times.
Now in those exchanges,
I just don't,
I think we're doing a lot
of arm chair quarterbacking.
Right.
Who the fuck knows what was going on?
You know what?
You're speculating whether or not you
wanted to be there after she got hit.
The problem is she
might've been just rocked.
And there's also the reality that she
was knocked out fucking cold a year ago
and it was a bad beating and then a
vicious head kick and there is something
about those goddamn neck kicks,
man.
There's something about when we,
when someone shins you in the neck,
like she got shin and your
whole body just goes limp.
You're doing so much damage in there.
But she had a 411 days off.
That's nice.
I think it was just bad strategy.
It's really simple.
The strategy was not good.
Amanda's just best as
possible to all those things.
Look,
I was the one who said like way early on,
I think Amanda's are most dangerous
challenge cause a man to hits so fucking
hard after she starts,
Sara Mcmann and uh,
when she,
when she was beaten up me
shows like Jesus Christ,
she punches harder than
anybody in that division.
She's got like dangerous
weapons with her hands.
But I think,
I really think there's a lot of people
that get CalEd like that and they are
never the same again.
I agree that they can't absorb a shot
anymore and then also in your brain
according to chocolate down.
And he was telling me about it like,
because he,
you know,
chuck was so tough that he would like
just fucking use his chin sorta like
Lineker does.
Like it's part of his defense,
like knowing that he can absorb shots
and after a while his brain was like,
hey man,
fuck you.
Like his brain was just like,
we're not going to do this
and just cause your shit.
Yeah,
just shuts off early.
I also think tech,
there's a certain level where they're,
where they're that great and you look
at like a tiger woods and Mike Tyson.
When that foundation gets a little shaky,
there's just never the same.
Yeah,
that's true.
It's just never,
they're like,
I'm not God's gift to the Eoc.
Exactly know them and we
gods don't give a shit.
Exactly.
And then like we said,
even if she was undefeated
and she saw it fought,
Nunez Nunez going to give her a problems
because if you watch like the Misha
Tate fight Meisha Tate like
even though she beat me,
she tight twice.
Me,
she'd take,
gave her a hard time.
There's some good scrambles.
Beach Dade hit her with some punches.
If Amanda Hits You with punches like that,
you're fuck,
you can't make mistakes.
You're in trouble.
Yeah.
She's like,
oh,
like in a lot of ways she's like a female
rumble in that she might not be able
to close this show with
one shot like rumble Ken.
But if you make mistakes,
you get stung so bad and you
see it with Sara McMann fights.
A perfect example,
she cracked Sarah with a right hand.
You see her.
Her whole face is like,
what the like nobody hits them like that.
Nobody and she's long a man that catches
you on the end of those punches too.
She,
she's great at distance.
I also think that the game's
evolving so fast where Amanda,
all she cares about is being champ.
All she does is train.
That's the only thing she gives a fuck up.
I think we saw the same
thing in the Dominick Cruz,
uh,
Cody Garbrandt fight.
All Cody wants to do is be champ.
Dominic's doing analyst's work he is for.
So I think there's,
there's this kind of change of hands
right now where you're seeing these guys
who were there all in.
And that's what you have to do to
be in this game this day and age.
Guys are too good there too.
Good.
And I think you're dead right.
I think you're dead right about that.
Oh,
here we go.
We'll watch the whole thing live now.
Give us a volume young Jamie.
So here it is.
So that jab landed with five seconds.
Jab right there.
Watch says she's down there.
Right there.
Yeah.
See,
so she stung.
10 seconds in.
We're at four 43 were 15 seconds
in and she's already got,
she's fucked right there.
She's fuck.
That was a super hard right hand.
And this is bad.
It's hard to watch.
It's real hard to watch
a boom to the body,
to she rip that shot to the body.
So like the idea that she didn't want
to be there 10 seconds into the fight.
She didn't know what the fuck was going.
Oh,
they're left to the right hand
in that right hand behind it.
This is horrific,
man.
It's tough.
A lunch,
boom,
boom.
God Damn.
Stop touching my herb.
Great stoppage.
But God damn Amanda Nunez as good.
She put a finger up to her mouth,
walked right up to Edmond,
looked in him when show gangster shit.
Well,
heart,
she's in another dimension.
There's no doubt about it.
She's got the,
you just know about.
She's tough.
And also she's got that thick
old neck that helps to go long.
Amanda's arms.
Yes.
She's great at keeping distance
and not crowding herself.
Well,
Amanda has a wide shoulders
and that helps too.
And then long arms as well.
And she's got awesome distance,
man.
Her,
her ability to catch you at the very
back of the punches were all the power is
because if you're punching someone
and you want to hit them here,
but they just move forward a foot,
you lose.
You lose like 90% of your power.
Yeah.